normally when an editor gets involved in
a film production area it can it can be
several potential points sometimes it
could be a couple of weeks for a couple
of months beforehand if you're required
to do a lot of prep work if there are
sort of animatics or action sequences
which need to be determined beforehand
it's very useful to have the editor
available to sort of put that together
to work with stumped teams and other
people to sort of see proof-of-concept
on jobs which were more kind of straight
drama jobs you sometimes tend to start
on sort of day 2 of the shoot day one of
course being the first day of filming in
which you may just be setting up your
edit suite and then potentially day 2 is
the first day of rushes that you have
available and you're there with your
team literally assembling the film as
they're shooting which is a useful thing
because of course a director editing
point can then get back to you and say
how does last week's rushes look how
does this sequence look and then you
have the ability as yet a sort of maybe
give them some feedback so say well you
know that's all good but maybe we could
do with an extra insert shot here and
because you're the one that's sort of
seeing it cut together and of course as
they're filming you know you have the
advantage of maybe seeing where these
extra things could could take place and
usually they're pretty good if you get
in touch with the director or the script
supervisor you can sort of say you know
it's it's really good but we have a
little issue here maybe this is
something we could try and resolve so
they tend to get you from the beginning
of the shoot through the whole shoot
period and then you get a small amount
of turnaround time to sort of complete
what is you'd call the editor's assemble
which will be the first thing the
director tends to watch when he comes in
so it'll be he's kind of your your
assemble of the entire film you then
work effectively on the director's cuff
roughly about a ten ten week period on
average where he then turns it into kind
of his or her vision which then gets
presented to the studio you then spend
even more months doing previews in front
of an audience changing scenes all notes
come flooding in from producers left
right and center there may be some
reshoots involved at
arranging material that they can view on
set - to assist in that up until picture
lock now some editors will actually end
their jobs there and potentially move on
to something else other editors will
actually then see the remaining process
through with the director so you will be
asked to attend the grade the sound mix
various technical kind of reviews visual
effects reviews and if anything that is
possibly the most intense period because
there always seems to be a tremendous
rush at the end to sort of get all that
done in time to deliver to the studio
as an editor that's that's that's also
potentially when you're not actually
editing still a quite an interesting
part of the process because you know you
and the director are sort of a team sort
of guiding guiding the film through to
its finish and ultimate delivering in
terms of your editorial team you always
like to work with people who you've
worked with before because they know
your shorthand and they know your kind
of quirks and they kind of like and
second-guess you and it's and it's
fantastic you know the editors may be
flying the plane but it's the editorial
team that's actually keeping us up in
the air and we had an incredible team on
baby driver we had Jerry Ramsbottom
first assistant who I'd worked with
before probably the best best first
since I've ever worked with James
panting who was the VFX editor and
Jessica Medlicott who was a second
assistant editor and also helped out in
some VFX editing as well you rely on
that team 100% and they have a habit of
like I say anticipating what you need
you tend to ask them a series of almost
impossible tasks it's a little bit like
um you know Alice Through the Looking
Glass because you always seem to think
that they do six impossible things
before breakfast because you know what's
required of them and not just from an
editorial sense but this arranging shots
to go up to the VFX departments and
bringing those back in integrating them
sending umpteen versions of cuts out to
the sound Department to executive
producers I don't envy their their
positions certainly on a major project
but I do envy the way they tend to
project manage they let you just get on
with the job of
and literally you know you're there with
the director you know I'm there with
Edgar and you feel like there's nothing
else going on just so the two of you can
consider it but there's this whole team
really sort of propping you up and and
enabling you to sort of do the work that
you're you're there to do so I
absolutely could not do what I do
without without their support
baby driver actually was was unique
actually and it was possibly the
culmination of the way Edgar and I had
started working potentially a little bit
on the reshoots for a film Edgar did a
few speckled Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
where I came on set and did some onset
editing for the additional photography
that developed a little bit more on the
worlds end where he asked me to be on
set for all the action pieces so we can
put them together as they were being
shot in problem-solve but then with baby
driver because there was such an
incredible mix of music and live action
and drama and dialogue and stunts and
everything Edgar said you know what it
would be really good if you were on set
the entire time and in actual fact
that's actually what happened I mean not
with Santa the fact that I had actually
worked with Edgar on and off for five
years prior to that helping him prep
stuff even before we kind of shot a
frame I'd had a very long gestation
period with him in helping to sort of
put sound sequences together and then
table reads with sound effects and music
and a lot of prep and animatics I mean
even but you know just before we started
shooting baby driver we actually had the
whole film as an animatic and we could
show all the eight roadies head of
departments in Atlanta the entire film
as basically drawn or storyboard which
was a fantastic thing to have for
reference being on set with Edgar I mean
this actually meant not even working in
a truck or a van or something I actually
had a little onset trolley a mag liner
and was literally on the front line of
the crew and there so there's the DOP
there's video assist and there I was so
literally on almost every shot of on
baby driver hook I could tell you where
I was just out of shot and Edgar at that
point said you know we need to make sure
that every shot sort of works for the
Edit and it was a very interesting mix
of production and post-production almost
occurring at the same time actually in
as much as the shot had to work for the
Edit as much as the Edit had to work for
the shot
it was symbiotic one had to basically
satisfy the other we couldn't shoot it
then come back to England to where we
did all the post and suddenly realize we
have a whole raft of issues you know
timings out and there's various
technical issues we wanted to make sure
that we came back from Atlanta with all
the footage if not cut to a fine degree
but at least assembled that we knew we
weren't going to have any any issues and
that was an incredible challenge
probably the hardest job I've ever done
but at the same time probably the most
fun I've ever had to sort of be out
there you know at that process and at
that moment of creation I certainly
haven't done anything quite like that
before for me I realized the number the
number one thing fun enough is not
actually a technical thing it's actually
an emotional thing it's enthusiasm and
it's the one thing that I am not really
reminded of but proven to me time and
time again that if you can be
enthusiastic about what you do and even
if you're in a moment where you know
maybe the shoots not going well the
directors feeling a little bit unsure
about things you know if you're there at
that point sort of so know it look have
a look what we've done it's amazing you
know and and just feeling really
positive
it's incredible energy to give out to
people because people will take that on
board it's incredible how people love to
you know to soak up enthusiasm and I'm
not saying you know the editor is the
only enthusiastic person on the crew I
mean that happens but that is something
that time and time again if you show
positivity and enthusiasm and keenness
that could get you so much further I
would say that potentially even
outweighs a percentage the amount of
technical ability that you actually have
I mean I would say for any aspiring
editor certainly if you can you know
it's always good doing your own projects
that's how I started running around with
my father's you know home video camera
and trying to put things together
teaching myself how to how to cut
watching hundreds and thousands of
television programs and movies and you
know which my mum hated but I put down
as research and just sort of analyzing
how things were done and also of course
when you start you know I found a good
ways to kind of almost break down a
scene out of one of your favorite films
how did they put that together maybe try
and emulate that style learn how that
was put together before maybe adopting
it to your own method and certainly you
know if you can get on a on a on a
project once again show enthusiasm even
if it's tiny project for maybe you know
a university or a friend or a colleague
who's doing something and nowadays with
the proliferation of Technology it's
incredible that you know every laptop
has effectively all the tools to finish
a project in a way that you know 20 30
years ago we couldn't even conceive of
to have that technology in in the
bedrooms the tools are all there and the
you know the the democratization of this
means that anybody who has an interest
has the ability to have the kid and
learn to teach themselves or or to do a
course and my best way was practical
experience and if you show the right
amount of enthusiasm and maybe get a gig
as you know an assistant if you can jump
on that ladder you know it may seem like
a slow start but if you persevere and if
you're keen one day you know that call
will will come and someone will
recognize you and offer you the gig and
then you're off one scene in particular
I remember there is a shootout in baby
driver in a warehouse and it's to a
track called tequila and this particular
version was recorded in 1970 by a group
I think called the button-down brass and
in the middle of it is a fantastic
drum solo Edgar came up with his
brilliant idea why doesn't the as per
the character of baby and in fact the
kind of whole undercurrent of the film
in which real life seemed to magically
synchronize to the music that babies
listened to on his on his headphones why
doesn't the gunbattle happen to fall in
to the exact beat of the drum solo and
so he designed this sequence with
the stunt guys and our choreographer
Ryan Heffington that actually every shot
fired by our characters and the the gang
in in the scene all magically fit to the
beat so the bullet the bullet shot the
bullet hits and the impacts and the the
firing bang on time so that's the
sequence where we basically had to break
down you know every drum riff every
little sort of power little lure you
know Tom fill or cymbal crash
effectively we analysed and we thought
okay so there's four four been theorized
is it gonna be for lots of gunfire there
and then that character will do it and
then you've got to get a reaction shot
in there but you've got to get back in
time because there's another but then
you'll see who's firing that then so
then an animatic was then created along
those lines where every single bit of
gunfire had a storyboard which is great
because on paper and pen and paper you
can make anything happen and it works
perfectly then there's the small matter
of actually happening make that happen
practically on set so not only were we
on night shoots at that point so you're
working the odd hours but then you know
you're literally putting this together
shot by shot and you have a very
complicated set up on set you have the
music being fed into the actor they have
little earpieces there you have music
being Center Edgar he's got dialogue in
one headphone music in the other a split
of the sounds gotta get sent to me in
the little editorial department and so
that notwithstanding you know you then
try and you and then you then put it
together shot by shot and then it comes
down to well has the actor kind of done
it on time can he actually fire fast
enough to the beat of course they've
rehearsed this this isn't just you know
making it up on the night but then of
course the shot is turned over to you
and like what can you do in literally
the the the seconds that you have
because no they will yell cut and Edgar
will just and shout out for the other
side of the set Paul how does that look
is it good and you just have to very
quickly in sudden you realize there's a
hundred pairs of eyes where the whole
cast and crew are something just waiting
for you to sort of very quickly dropped
a shot in if you need to adjust or
whatever and you can say yeah it's great
for then Edgar will feel
we've got the shot that all needs to get
kind of broken down into its constituent
parts and that then you put that
together over a couple of evenings
that's followed then by a very difficult
if memory serves a Steadicam shot which
is basically a 360 so the camera is just
traveling round and round and round so
now you do have to be incredibly careful
to hide all the cast and all the crew
and all the gear has to be hidden
because the camera you know there's
nothing to hide from when the cameras
going right around and set but then you
have to choreograph with the actors that
they are in the right place at the right
time and when the camera is there
this actors there and that actors there
so when everything gets broken down like
that and including the final shoot at
the end everything has to get just
broken down into its constituent parts
you concentrate on every little area and
and that was the big advantage like I
say to being to being on set like you
know and we finished that scene over the
course of a week knowing that to some
degree every shot was in the bag
literally and you know it actually ended
up becoming one of the kind of the
highlight points
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]